Oui, c'est sûr, mais les blagues sur les sens, je les trouve un peu bidons.
Oui, tout à fait ! Au revoir !
Eh ! dis donc Jamie, j'ai...
Ah non... Faut jamais dire Jamy !
J'ai fait un rêve super chelou cette nuit !
J'ai rêvé qu'il y avait une forêt, une chèvre, et là d'un coup...
J'ai commencé à... baiser la chèvre.
Et c'est pas tout hein Jamie !
Je disais des trucs vraiment chelous dans mon rêve, du style...
Pour moi, j'ai pas de problèmes psychologiques.
Pour moi, un trou c't'un trou.
Jamy, s'il te plaît, tu crois que c'est grave ?
Mais non, ce n'est pas grave du tout !
Pour comprendre un peu mieux tout ça, direction le cerveau !
En voiture Simone !
Jamy ! C'est Marcel.
Ah oui, c'est vrai !
Ça y est là ! Je crois que je suis dans mon cerveau.
C'est hyper grand !tu verrais ça... Bien plus que ce à quoi je pensais, hein !
Par contre Jamie, euh... On dirait que c'est divisé en trois parties...
et j'ai pas vu la trace d'une seule chèvre...
Eh! dis donc, Jamy, tu pourrais pas m'en dire un peu plus s'il te plaît ?
Pas de problème Freud !
En fait le cerveau traite l'information de différentes façons.
Par exemple, le coin de table que je me prends dans la gueule
ou la tristesse que je ressens
c'est des choses dont je me rends compte,
c'est des choses que je comprends
et donc ça appartient à la conscience.
D'ailleurs on dit : "prendre conscience de quelque chose".
Après, c'est pas le seul système psychique.
Il y a le préconscient qui est à la limite de la conscience
et qui s'apparente à peu près à ma mémoire.
Enfin il y a un troisième espace psychique.
On a tous eu des peurs ou des pulsions qu'on arrive pas trop à expliquer...
Euh... Je suis sûr qu'il y a pas que moi qui...
Qui a fait ça à une chèvre.
Enfin bref ! Il y a un troisième espace psychique,
qui n'est ni conscient, ni préconscient, et s'appelle inconscient.
Cet inconscient, on peut en avoir des aperçus, avec euh... les lapsus !
Lap-suce... Mais sans les dents hein s'il te plait.
Mais aussi les actes manqués, n'hésitez pas à voir la description pour plus d'informations.
Mais aussi en analysant les rêves, comme celui de Freud avec la chèvre.
Hein Freud ?
... Freud...
A mais dis donc Jamy ! Euh...
Je me suis un peu perdu là, mais je crois que j'ai trouvé mon inconscient...
Monsieur Seguin ?
Mais qu'est ce que vous faites avec cette chèvre ?
Mais bien sûr, Jamy !
Mon rêve s'explique par ce qu'il y a dans mon inconscient !
Et dis donc Jamy, comment une chose fait pour se retrouver ici dans mon inconscient ?
Il doit y avoir plein de trucs différents du coup...
Ça a l'air super large comme espace !
Et ouais mon gars, c'est large comme ma b***
Même si toutes les pensées ne sont pas inconscientes, elles y passent forcément à un moment donné.
En fait l'activité psychique commence par l'inconscient,
et si elle veut accéder au système conscient, elle doit passer l'épreuve de la censure.
Si la censure lui refuse l'accès, on parle alors de refoulement.
Pas vrai la petite voix ?
D'ailleurs, suite au refoulement dans l'inconscient,
il nous arrive de même plus vouloir nous souvenir de ce qu'on a vécu.
C'est le cas par exemple de Sarah dans Jumanji,
quand elle refuse de croire qu'Alan Parrish a vraiment disparu dans le jeu.
Et dis donc Jamy, je suis allé faire un tour dans mon inconscient...
Et... Je suis tombé sur lui, là !
...Chèvres, plus des filles, voler des voitures, voler des chèvres, caresser des voitures, manger des filles...
Ce personnage que j'ai demandé à mon pote de jouer et qui le rend complètement ridicule,
c'est le "ça".
Le "ça" fait partie d'un système de trois instances, mouvements ou phénomènes qui se passent ici,
qui sont le "ça", "surmoi", et "moi".
En fait le "ça" il faut le prendre comme un réservoir à pulsions et désirs de l'homme.
Je vais le symboliser par une lampe car c'est l'énergie psychique.
Cette énergie, elle passe au travers du "surmoi", que je symbolise ici par un filtre bleu.
Le "surmoi" c'est les barrières que tu te construis
avec par exemple les interdits de la société, l'éducation de tes parents, mais aussi tes propres règles.
C'est ce qui fait que tu vas pas faire l'amour avec ta copine en plein milieu de la rue.
C'est pour ça que j'ai symbolisé le "surmoi" par un filtre bleu.
Et du coup, tu vas me demander ce que c'est que le "moi".
Bah c'est simple, c'est ce qui résulte du conflit entre "ça" et "surmoi" :
donc ici, c'est la lumière bleue.
Eh! Jamy, regarde !
C'est la grosse teuf dans mon inconscient, on attend plus que toi, viens !
Oh non ! Oh ça fait déjà la deuxième fois cette semaine.
Jamy deux sans trois !
Oh ce Freud... Il a pas le cerveau-lent, ok, Marcel on y retourne !
... comme une crêpe !